I'm mark I am from Washington DC I work
for Microsoft and just kind of there we
go so I'm a technical solution
specialist at Microsoft I focus on the
azure cloud stack for data and AI so
everything that's related to all of our
managed services and our on premises
stuff related to data science analytics
artificial intelligence we're not I help
the federal government folks in the
federal government adopt our platform
and what's been really cool is that
there are actually pockets of the
federal government that are definitely
using our more and more people are using
our and you know it's a lot of fun so
about me just want a disclaimer so I am
affiliated with a bunch of organizations
again Microsoft
so yes data community DC data community
C was started after Harlan moved to DC
we I was working the Armada up then we
started the data science DC meet up
together and over the years grew to over
20,000 people we have a reach of over
20,000 people across different programs
so Jared we have over 20,000 people it
doesn't matter it's 20,000 people let's
see what else I also am an adjunct
professor at Georgetown in a GW I teach
a big data course where I in the Masters
of analytics so I teach students how to
use Hadoop and spark and how to do a lot
of I would call it like systems / DevOps
/ Linux / everything else they don't
teach you in all the other classes and
really help them embrace this idea of
working with computer computing systems
right because it's very different for
you to start up in our session and you
know do read underscore CSV read in a
file
do some stuff write CSV back to working
in large-scale systems working in
production environments being able to
interface with other types of code and
things like that so again my opinions
today are my opinions alone and that's
that just a little bit of shout out why
reinvent the wheel
I hate making slides so so I am just
reusing stuff that's publicly available
I have modified some stuff and I have
added
huntin so a shout out to my Microsoft
peers shout out to Hadley I saw him over
there
shot it - Jady Jady there we go
and on that note so let's see
show of hands who has a big data problem
Wow okay alright that's fine
maybe you'll have it by the end of this
talk who has experience to do okay a few
of you who has experience park couple
you all right who has a spiritual Scylla
okay who loves our okay alright so the
idea of this talk is really to show you
that you have options of working with
big data you know you might be scared of
it especially you know I know a lot of
people work with smallish datasets and
that's fine and you know I come from
doing large-scale data analytics usually
from a business context that's my
background I have a background in
mechanical engineering I have an MBA yes
I'm a data scientist in an MBA weird
combination but over the last few years
of my career when I started getting into
the art community and doing data
analytics and I started learning are
after running the meetup I really fell
in love with the community and really
started using all these available tools
I started using Hadoop and are back in
2010 there's still a couple of Stack
Overflow questions from that time of
course JD was a good contributor to that
because he wrote the first PI simulation
on R and Hadoop streaming like in 2010
that was a lifetime ago but really the
the fact is that the ecosystem has
matured and I know that for many our
users getting into sort of this big data
stack or big data ecosystem is sort of
you know it's sort of like a little bit
of a fear so hopefully by the end of
today I will take take away those fears
and give you the the tools or give you
the ideas to go and let you go and play
around with big data
oh I'm also here to recruit speakers to
the DC media
okay so first slide stolen from JD via
Hadley Wickham or vice versa so you know
when we talk about big data or at least
when I talk about big data
it's really you it's really a lot from
the business context where you have a
lot of long data right
I think Yuri made a URI or Sandro made
reference to like you know clicks and
and and logs and stuff like that you
have a lot a lot a lot a lot of
transactions normally you're not working
with all of it right you're always
aggregating and Buckett again or
whatever so the idea of working with big
data you know 10 years ago was probably
you know really getting your big big
data into teeny data and then pulling it
out of your cluster loading it up to R
on your local machine or Python or
whatever and kind of doing your
visualizations doing your analysis
whatever so today I think it's the the
story has changed a little bit
you know big data still big but you can
take it down to less big data because
you have the computing power to be able
to work with individual data sets on
relatively large machines so case in
point you know you can start up a
cluster not a cluster you can start up a
single instance on the cloud that has
several gigabytes of memory and you know
do your analysis there and then but then
there's the other side of it which is
it's really big it's already spread it's
already scattered and how do you work
with that in the old days you would have
to kind of figure out how to extract
data from databases largely assets
gigabytes I'm not not sort of talking
about the petabyte scale I'm keeping it
to the you know hundreds of gigabytes
scale here extract it and figure out how
to work with it so today with the with
the advent of the cloud it's really easy
to work with and there's other tools
about it so again the same idea of the
big data that you most of the time you
can take big data
reduce it to a less bigger data set and
then work with it at the times you can't
there are tools for you and and that's
really the focus of this presentation
and the thing is also that today
especially with the advent of IOT
there's a lot of data that's being
generated and streaming all the time so
you have to figure out how to work with
that and that's long data that you have
to aggregate and ingest so a lot of the
work that I've done over the years has
really been about making day to work
finding tools like setting up the right
tools and environments for folks to do
their analytics right because as I said
before it's really different to start up
float up your lap you start up your
laptop download a data set load it into
R do your stuff save it do a model
whatever it's really different when
you're working with large data sets it's
also very different when you're working
in a just in a in a shared user
environment when you're trying to break
down silos you see this a lot in the
federal government but you also see this
a lot in industry which is every
organization within a company or a
reservation in every group has their own
sets of tools their own sets of methods
and I think we're gonna see this theme
over and over today right but the idea
is sending up a analytics environment
for multiple people is not easy so part
of this is also number one knowing the
tools that are available to you and
number two is there also is an aspect of
I'll call it data engineering for a lack
of a better term that you do need to
know and do need to be a little bit
aware of or proficient in to really be
able to take advantage of this ecosystem
so you know this is our working in in
general right and in normal and
large-scale so we take a dataset we
loaded into memory on a single machine
there's been a lot of work over the
years to make the data replication less
expensive and you know thanks to all the
folks in in our studio and the our
community that have taken the you know
the tide of us and all the other tools
that make it a lot easier to work with
but inherently our is single threaded
there's no parallel there's no inherent
parallelism so there's many many ways to
approach this problem so five years five
years ago I don't think you can see that
but five years ago we gave a talk in DC
about our for Big Data and there's all
sorts of I know you can't see it but
this is just like a little mind map of
of all different things and the big the
big boys back then were down here like
reap our hype which is on our Hadoop
integration RMR and some of the early
stuff that the revolution analytics team
was working on the xdf revoscaler and
all that stuff today I think the
ecosystem is a little bit different so
you have you know the biggest thing what
I think really makes the reduces the
barrier to entry are these packages
appear so you've got spark R which is
actually part of the spark ecosystem it
actually is built into mainline spark
there is sparkly are a package written
by the art studio folks that really
lowers the barriers to entry for our
users into the spark ecosystem there's
revolution the real scale R which is
part of the revolution distribution of R
which is not part of Microsoft and then
there's h2o which is a machine learning
platform for distributed data there's
other other tools right the stuff on so
the stuff on the top is what I'm going
to focus on today the first the first
two actually and then just just so you
know there's also other packages
available if you don't know about them
so there's big memory
there's FF and kind of the 4-h and do
parallel backends which allow you to do
parallel computing on your local machine
taking advantage of multi-threading
I mean multiple cores and or setting it
up and something sorry something like
this where you have
perhaps a cluster of our machines where
you can actually distribute your work
and this is more along the advent of
high performance computing that's not
what I'm gonna be focusing on today but
this is just good for reference these
are some of the different packages and
distributions and how they you know the
advantages they give you so you know
cran like regular are works on single
machines these other packages gives you
a bit the ability to work on single or
multiple machines or use clusters as the
backend and then then we move on to
spark so so not many people use spark
but are you guys familiar with spark
okay so for those that don't know or for
those to do so spark is an open source
project it's basically a distributed
computing platform for general computing
and it's gotten traction because what it
changed is that it actually uses memory
and/or disk as opposed to just using
disk Hadoop is just a batch process read
and readout which was very effective
when it came out you know not a lot of
folks were using Hadoop back in the day
what's and they still are because Hadoop
is really or Hadoop and MapReduce is
very good for certain kinds of jobs
there are other kinds of tasks where
Hadoop is really not that great and
that's where SPARC I think has really
made a big impact on the large data on
the big data ecosystem so what SPARC
allows you to do is really take
advantage of memory in memory
computations so that works really well
for machine learning where you have to
do multiple passes on your data you know
you can't sometimes you can't do machine
learning in batch mode or if you can but
it's gonna read it once read it a second
time reader to third time and so on and
so on and when your data is in the multi
gigabyte or multi petabyte scale you
have a time problem so SPARC gives you
the capability of doing large-scale
computations it really abstracts a lot
of the cluster management for you and
the these are kind of the building block
the building blocks for SPARC so on the
top you've got the API is that interface
with SPARC so SPARC is written in scala
so of course there's a skylight pi
there's a Python API there's also
our API and and Java Scala and Java are
interchangeable the four building blocks
kind of the the different threads of
spark would it gives you ability to do
so you have sparks equal so sparks equal
gives you the ability of doing
structured data analysis using sequel
like commands then sparks streaming is
used you know doing analysis of real
time data as its flowing spark EMA lib
so the the spark team has actually coded
a lot of machine learning algorithms
already that are available for spark you
probably get about 90% of the way there
with what's out there with this with
spark and then graphics is a graph API
on top of spark and then spark is what's
cool about spark is that it gives you
the ability it you can run it on
different kinds of clusters you can run
it on a Hadoop cluster you can run on a
standalone spark cluster you can ran it
stinked I know on a single machine and
it lives alongside Hadoop and MapReduce
so spark R gives you a you know spark R
is built into spark it actually gives
you the ability to interface with the
rdd's which is the Scala Scala's sort of
low-level data object or data structure
that's available in SPARC and then over
the years there's been the development
of higher level API source part
including spark sequel and the spark
data frame
that's where sparkly art comes into the
place I will just jump here so sparkly
what sparkly are allows you to do is it
really allows you to use spark as a
back-end and it really fits in well with
the tidy verse so it just it creates the
connection object for you it translates
tidy code into spark sequel and it runs
stuff in the backend it doesn't do
everything but it gets you I'll say 90%
of the way there and you know your Cu to
them so think of it as using R as a
front-end right you're using your are
console whether it is on your local
laptop or it is running on an R server
on the cloud so your our instance
becomes your interface to the cloud so
that also abstracts the
the fear of dealing with with clusters
and and kind of dealing with all of the
DevOps and like I said data engineering
stuff that that comes attached to that
spark are sparkly are what the spark
thank you so I just found this blog post
recently this fellow Edie just kind of
did a comparison of spark aren't
sparkler so spark are is part of the
spark distribution it gets installing on
a cluster when you install spark as of I
think 1.6 right now it works it like 2 2
or 2 3 and then sparkle ER is I think
it's at 0.7 but it's it's it's
progressed a lot over the last year and
a half so you know again thanks to the
our studio team and everyone involved
with building all those great tools for
us to use this gives you a high-level
overview of kind of the difference so so
spark are is really meant to interact
more more you can do a lot with both I
think some of them have particular
strengths and weaknesses so spark are
gives you the ability to interact mostly
with the RDD which is the low level data
structure in spark where a sparkly are
gives you a better way to interact with
the higher level objects which are the
smart data frames one thing I read
that's not necessarily here and and this
is what kind of contradicts is I my
understanding was that running arbitrary
code or user-defined functions was
actually easier to do with spark are
than with sparkly are but and this says
otherwise
again I don't know much about that but
the key thing here is this is the tie
diverse compatibility so as you see here
basically you can just write a deep liar
statement you start your I mean there's
the code for starting your clusters not
here but let's say you start your
cluster your interface with the cluster
you create your object and then you just
refer to your table as if it was a data
frame and you can use that object as
part of your tidy code and then it that
gets shipped off into the cluster in the
backend so you know I guess it's part of
the title verse now
and so one thing I did want to mention
is one aspect of of working with big
data that's really hard is setting up
your environment you know there are many
cloud providers out there I work for one
of them and but truth be told is one of
the challenges that I I was faced with
early on was really setting up the
environment the right way because it's
not just starting a cluster right you
can start a cluster really easily but if
you want to work with are if you want to
work with our studio if you want to work
with all your our packages there's a
really a lot of devops work that's
involved there and before I used a sure
I did all that stuff manually and it was
a royal pain I'm not saying this because
I work for Microsoft I'm saying this
because I truly believe it the Azure
platform really gives you makes it
really easy to work with these tools so
you can actually start up a cluster with
our and our studio already installed and
all you have to do is run with it so
that for for many folks that don't have
that skill set of data engineering
sasada and DevOps all that sort of stuff
it makes it really really easy so and we
have a whole slew of tools right you
know we have so there's our there's
Microsoft our then there's revolution
our but as you can see it really fits
into the to the Big Data ecosystem we
recently launched the data BRICS
integration with Azure data BRICS are
the folks that actually wrote spark the
folks behind data BRICS are the folks
that wrote spark and it's now fully
integrated with the Azure platform and
it's truly amazing it's really a cool
interface because it it's even higher
level interface than using spark or na
Hadoop cluster it's a spark cluster and
this is a platform as a service it just
sort of takes advantage of running
everything for you but like I said I'm
really not trying not to be pitchy
because I'm not but it really makes it
easy to work with and I'm happy to talk
offline about the tools that's and how
to get you folks involved so some
parting shots so don't don't be afraid
of the big data tool
the ecosystem has evolved there are more
options for you out there you know
there's HPC options there's
multi-threading options there's spark
options there's Hadoop options I would
encourage you to learn a little bit
about data engineering leverage in
database analytics as much as you can so
you don't have to move data around just
a little bit of synote a lot of times
the examples that are available online
refer to a data set
most of these are open but they're not
readily available so over time I've been
collecting those publicly available data
sets and making them more readily
available you know they're not zipped
they're actually ready to use so I have
- I have a s3 bucket and an azure bucket
with some large data sets including the
New York City Taxi and and others and I
just would encourage you to try Azure as
a platform so please come visit us in DC
if you'd like to speak at DC let me know
we would love to have you so thank you
very much
[Applause]